are we ready here
I am okay all right well I think we're
ready okay so for people joining this
live stream We are continuing our review
of astronomy functionality
and where have we got to okay yesterday
about astral position and about the
second argument of Astro position right
exactly and and thinking more about it I
wanted to elaborate on on an important
idea that I wasn't able to articulate
yesterday properly and so to do that I
think it's easy or useful to compared to
the Geo design and so in Geo we have two
main types of objects we have the
geoposition and and the opposition XYZ
Etc which are absolute identifiers of
position on earth like we have these two
for example
then we have the Geo displacements which
are like relative identifiers and so we
can say give me the displacement from
this first position to this second
position
and so we get this is the distance
emitters this is mango and so on now of
course the main point here is that the
displacement does not remember where it
started so we can use your destination
to say if we start at this first the
opposition with this data displacement
we get back the second one okay so so
the displacement is is a
instructions on how to compute a
geodesic
on the Earth
which are managed to be set up so
they're independent of the base point
which is not obvious you could do I mean
if the Earth was a weird shaped you know
one of those weird shaped moons that has
you know
whatever no no no no no no it's very
important to know the first so we cannot
compute the geodesic without knowing
this I know but you've got parameters
that are independent of where that first
the the parameters of the displacement
yes uh you know
if you imagine a metric yeah okay
what is the analog of this in general
relativity so we've got exactly that's
the thing we are going to discuss here
but the main point is that to compute a
geographic in any situation you always
needs a point and a vector
the the point and the vector that
indicates the direction in which you
start and and of course the length of
the of the jealousy so this is this is
essentially the vector
this gives you the direction in which
you have to start and because the the
secure this is flat sorry it's flat it's
playing this is two-dimensional
we just need an angle and then the
distance
but this idea always works a point and a
vector
now what is the situation in Astra so if
we did this in relativity we would have
to start with events we would have an
aster events they would be the
equivalent of geoposition we would have
coordinates and then we would have to
say in which coordinate system this is
given
the analog of geoposition XYZ and things
like that the uh I would say the the
analog yes the analog of any of these
which are all for absolute positions
it will be an aster event we just give
numbers and a coordinate system
right and then we would take two of
these events which are like points in a
space time
and we we would compute the displacement
between them right yep
coordinate system is datum right it's
like which geolipsoid Etc yes yes
exactly yeah we can think of it that way
um yes it's the thing that physically
gives meaning to these numbers
although there's also Geo position XYZ
isn't there which is which is not with
respect to a datum it's some absolute no
no it is it is also with respect to uh
datum do you need to know an ellipsoid
well a data the data include includes
the orientation of the three axis
okay so different items have a slightly
different orientations of the three axis
okay
yeah so yeah so there is a second
argument in the opposition XYZ 2. mm-hmm
okay but so the point is that we would
have this astral displacement and this
astral displacement is the thing you
have in mind when you think of
is this light like is this a space like
is this time like right it is the
numbers inside will be the vector that
indicate how to start the geodesic in
space-time exactly as digital
displacement that's a four Vector in
fact it would be a four Vector in our
case yes
and so in Astro we are interested in
light observations
right and so we focus on on the case of
light but this could be generalized to
an object that computes all these other
kinds of geodesics in space times
yeah I mean in a sense maybe what we're
building here
is a way of handling space-time
coordinates I mean you know spatial
coordinates
are sort of trivial to handle they're
just what we handle in lists and you
know all our learning algebra and all
this kind of stuff you know special
coordinates are straightforward but the
minkowski metric or something beyond the
govsky metric
it's not so easy to handle and perhaps
what we're doing here I mean you know
we're doing it in the astronomy case
but we could as well you know this could
be you know somebody's Bose Einstein
condensate you know thing where there's
where speed of light matters for some
reason I'm just I'm making that comment
I I think there's an argument that this
notion of space-time event and so on
could be actually space-time events not
Astro event
yes I I agree with that I mean the one
comment is that the the space this
purely spatial case can also be already
complicated if the shape of the object
you are working on is complicated
yes right so it's true that in
relativity we have the added
complication of minkowsky of the sign
changed for time
um but so the the thing I now that we
have seen this difference
now what is astral position sitting here
I'm sorry sorry yeah just backing up to
your comment about the essentially
differential geometry comment that you
made before yeah
um you know right now you know the datum
is still on the left side but to do
General differential geometry on an
arbitrary surface
we've got something which is a
generalization of a datum and we could
imagine and we had that guy working for
a while on that on that problem
of giving an arbitrary surface I mean
given an arbitrary region object so
Roger this is a you know given a region
object
and you want to know the distance on
that weird-shaped you know banana or
something right yeah between two points
yeah
I mean
is that something we have right now we
don't but we we you know it's been one
of those it's
I want I'm curious to hear I mean it
sounds like you're kind of relativity
sort of interest in it but it actually
is is useful in in many other contexts
for planning uh problems for instance
um
to find sort of a shortest path you know
and there are many
variations of it but this thing of
computing it on a surface
on a mesh it's not that hard
so I don't know if how far that guy got
but it's it's not that hard
we don't have it but but you know
I was thinking that the use case is kind
of like path planning basically
well I mean there are plenty of pure
Matthews cases as well the final
surfaces
well yeah
not completely uninteresting ones either
no no and so on sure yeah
okay all right so
okay so keep going I'll say yes so
so the thing is what is Astro position
in in in the light of of this discussion
so what we are doing in Astro position
is essentially what we do already in the
opposition e and U which is that we
store a place and then we store a vector
that communicates that place with the
place you are interested in
yes right so that's the position we are
installing the observation event
the the base you were calling yesterday
plus the numbers are how to start a
light geodesic that would
take me to the place I'm interested in
well hold on a second
what you were doing before
was to say here's the thing I'm looking
at and here's the place I'm at now
that's presumably a geodesic between
those two but rather than
defining you know you're saying what the
end points of the geodesic are
right so the the
so when I say Astro position of Venus
I'm interested in
two things one is that I'm looking at
Venus from a place on Earth right now
that's an event of observation so I'm
starting the event of observation so
this date
and this location
and I'm storing also the orientation of
the frame with which I will Define these
three numbers these three numbers are
the are essentially the vector with
which the light arrives at me
so you see so it's a geodesic that comes
from a from Venus to me and I store the
vector that will allow me to reconstruct
the geodesic backwards in time and then
discover where Venus was at that point
so that's what
that's a nice clean description of
what's going on
okay so now what do you think that means
in terms of the design
well I wanted to introduce these
to find terminology and and structure
possible structure
right so right so yeah
well I mean so
really what you're saying is the first
point is there's an observation point
and a resolution event yes
so it's both position in space so these
are effectively three three numbers
because we know we are on the surface of
the Earth plus a date these two dates
are the same date it's just that it's
useful to store it in two forms to avoid
converting from one to the other but I I
might change that cash it okay it's the
same date okay but but so the basic
Point here is we've got
it's just very strange to call it
observation event
um
wasn't it
Observer I mean into Geographics
no there's no analog in Geographics
there's no no Astro Graphics I mean yeah
I know it was Observer which I don't
like at all because an observer is like
I'm thinking of Arthur Eddington as an
observer you know
foreign
or whatever
um
perhaps this is the observation
rather than the Observer
yeah so I think that's closer to what it
is but but um
let's see some sort of setup
uh
it's complicated because I mean you're
right that
you know observation event just sounds
wrong because it's not
uh
uh I mean it's Observer position in
space and time
plus orientation of the frame in this
case
and there is also the coordinate system
it's interesting to see that this object
the opposition e and U it's assuming
always the horizon
frame yeah with a given orientation e
and U and Cartesian coordinates so what
this is doing it's generalizing to any
frame
and then these specifying the equivalent
of Cartesian e and U so this is saying
no I don't want Cartesian I want to
spherical coordinates and rather than e
and U I want
starting at the North estimate so this
would be
North e u
yeah so it's a different convention so
this this is all stored in in these two
things in this and this
actually we can say Astro position
of London
from here
and we are going to use the horizontal
frame as well
uh well I don't need to specify anything
else
and I'm going to use Cartesian
coordinates
and in the format enu
okay
so those numbers
are those numbers
but these are corrected for relativistic
stuff so they are very close to those
okay what on Earth does that mean so
astral position of London relative to
where is our Observer point where is our
Observer by default is here and no so
this is now
and here right
that's those are the defaults of Serbian
from here oh I see so here yeah wherever
your geolocation was
so now I can extract these and these of
course are in so I have this notation
which
so we could say Quantity
kilometers
that's very weird this way I guess uh no
sorry it doesn't work here okay so let's
change these to okay hold on hold on
hold on I'm still
internalizing here
what I mean here is that as the position
can work with things that are very close
like London from us yeah
I get it
okay
so all right so basically what you're
saying is
we need a word that's like it's beyond
frame It's a combination of frame
position location or maybe we don't need
a rope maybe it's just the second
argument the Astra position
and that's that's what it is and we say
astral position
is
this thing
in the coordinate system is that the
relativistic correction what is that
I can eliminate one by one so for
example firstly no please yes yes
magnificent but this is not what we
should be doing right now it's okay
I'm curious what that does but anyway I
look we we are not allowed our physics
moment here
no this is uh
okay
Etc so I can eliminate one by one and by
the way you should you should make
aberration Goes To None work just FYI
okay
okay um
okay
so
um all right so let's go back again so
the first argument of Astral position is
the thing you're looking at the and then
but it is so geoposition
by default is using absolute coordinates
on the earth with respect to a certain
datum
astral position
is necessary is using
let's see because of the because of the
light you know because of the relativity
issue you have to know where you're
looking at it from
and also because these things are moving
which is not the case in you know on the
Earth
you know things don't move
right so I think it's the
okay so basically what it is astral
position is the thing you're looking at
and then sort of
and then you've got this bundle which is
I mean I would feel more comfortable
about having a rapper Astro Observer
that is that bundle of here now frame
this is what I'm saying
it's not an option it's a it's a it's an
actual object
um an object that we can place in
various places yeah right
I see
actually
that's not a bad idea
because now you can store a bunch of
Observers
yes which is useful
and this is describing
an observer an astronomical Observer
where they are when they are
what frame they're using whether they're
dealing with refraction blah blah blah
yeah
it's a little weird that that refraction
is in the eye of the Observer so to
speak because refraction is either
happening or it's not
um well we have parameters here like
temperature
Etc so there are four parameters no I
understand that I understand that but
but that's the Observer is that the
destination the refraction is happening
not at the destination I mean here and
now in Horizon those are all destination
stories refraction is on the trip
the refraction doesn't that seem to you
like Optical like visual
Spectrum where it does does that happen
for x-rays
no no refraction is
is the question of how the yes it is
it's actually happening it's referring
to atmospheric refraction which means
visible light in the atmosphere is bent
if it was the next way it would just go
straight through right so this
implicitly assumes visual light
yeah which is you're right and that's
not really necessarily correct well we
do have here one of the four parameters
is uh wavelength
and this has some models that work for
several ranges of this
four parameters
this thing is quite difficult to compute
and this is some approximation
that gets more or less correctly what
happens near the Horizon and then so we
have basically two models one need for
observations near the Horizon another
one for the
observation is far from that place
okay so if I'm on Mars
um it doesn't have much refraction going
for it right right yeah the models we
have are for the Earth indeed
but you can specify if you know
the values of of these things in Mars
then you can use them
I see I doubt that will work because
it's got you know it's an atmosphere
with different no why would that work I
mean the the refraction the refractive
index
well actually the refractive index of a
gas right it's the Loren Lorenz Lorenz
lore or something gives refractive
indices of gases as I recall and I don't
know what it depends on
do you mean that this would also depend
on their chemical composition yeah some
I don't know whether it does I think it
maybe doesn't but I'm not sure
I don't know either
um
I mean in the end the refractive index
does depend on that for for a material
like but for you know it depends on
atomic
properties but for a gas it's not so
um if you're worried about refraction
for example there's another one which is
the precession notation model so these
are all things that we need to know
about the Earth
and and again it's not a property really
of the Observer it's more of the setup
of the observation
yeah
well maybe it's Astro observation
the last one is this one
okay
God
okay look it's the position
I mean
maybe astral position isn't the right
concept I don't know
um
maybe the the observation is a wrapper
around the position that the position
defines the position of the thing the
source object you see what I'm saying
with its frame and you know with it with
its coordinate system and all that kind
of thing it's just that is where Venus
is that's the position of where Venus is
and now you have to observe that
position from somewhere else
I'm not making sense
um sorry
yes why don't you choose docky tools
the low level tools
so there are all these parameters in the
observation I understand so what I'm
suggesting is maybe what we should do is
astral position really is
the actual raw position as it is in Geo
position
yeah
yeah look look here's what I would
suggest okay let's imagine that astral
position is the actual position so as to
a position of dated of Venus blah blah
blah could certainly give the position
of Venus at that time
right and it's in whatever frame is our
default frame okay
then the question of where is Venus
sort of projected onto our telescope
where we are is a wrapper around that
it's an astro observation
of this thing at a certain astral
position
I see the problem is the coordinate
system that you quote the astral
position in okay here's the issue astral
position of Venus is an absolute thing
you know where Venus is in some
coordinate system right yep
and then you know wrapping at
excuse me a wrapping astral observation
around that to say where does it appear
in the sky from me it all makes sense
okay what that is not dealing with is I
want to Simply type
the position of something in you know
I've got
this black hole merger just occurred at
this
you know
Galactic coordinate system position so I
I don't understand what maybe what we
need to do is the coordinate system that
the problem is that a natural coordinate
system in which the specify astral
positions is
the altitude Azimuth one or right
Ascension declination relative to where
you are on the Earth
but in order to use that coordinate
system you have to back project from
where you are so to speak
right so so this has been very well
developed for the solar system so in the
solar system there is this this is
called bodycentric coordinate reference
system and so we can give coordinates
everywhere in the solar system
at any given time for a time that is
defined by the by essentially the the
time at the center of the solar system
at the solar system Body Center
and then the same thing has been done
for the Earth
there is the Geo
um Celeste the geocentric Celestial
reference system
okay now is that where you can give
right extensions and declinations no
race Essentials and declinations are
angles of a vector of observation
so this is what I was discussing before
so if I know that the star rigel is that
this right Ascension declination which
you know Ptolemy had you know who
whoever had Pockets had tables that said
that yep
how do I type that in
is that gcrs or is it close to gcrs or
what
So when you say I I know that the
altitude and no no I said I said write
essential declaration yes bright
Ascension and declination of something
it means I used our inequatorial
reference frame
from the solar system by Center or from
the earth and I got these angles when I
looked at it
yes but it's not the solar system I mean
you know Ptolemy didn't use the solar
system barrier Center he used the Earth
exactly yeah and so if I type in his
coordinates and I say my coordinate
system is gcrs well I get the right
answer or not
the most correct one for for him would
be what we call the two equatorial
through a equinox frame okay fine but
there is a okay
so so basically what we're saying is
a literal object like Venus just has
some location
okay and a dated Venus or whatever has
some location at a certain time at the
specified time
um now you know exactly what the dated
means and how we back project the times
we have to talk about that but in a
first approximation
um
right so that this would be the
equivalent of of what an astronomer
would get
no I understand but what I'm much more
concerned about is if you say astral
position you type in
a right Ascension declination there yes
right then
it's all good right you just can say
okay
okay so with the right assumption
declination and that's probably the
default is that correct that if you
don't give a second argument and you
just give literal number
the default is the Horizon so altitude
has serious
which I think may be a mistake
um well it's the default it is the
closest to you so for an astronomer I
know but but in order to do that don't
you have to have
well okay maybe that's right okay but
that specifies
no but isn't that just totally confusing
everything again
look the whole point of Astral position
is it is a literal space-time point
not some back projector Judy sick
and I mean you know that astral position
in a writer Center and declination isn't
a space-time point
it's a Direction
because I'm getting sick
right these are direction from which we
can compute where
uh something was because we know it was
observed from some place
yeah we don't know how far we knew how
far away it was but that's very
different from saying Venus there which
is at a particular place at a certain
time
[Music]
well this is assumed to be on the
celestial sphere if you don't specify a
distance this is some sort of infinitely
extended
light Ray
wait a second wait a second
we're not talking light Ray here
yes
everything that is is always a light Ray
when it when it's involved
as an observation was it when it's
described as an observation
for example when we get this information
of where was this black hole merge
we get a direction which is very precise
and or relatively precise and it may be
not so precise in distance or it may be
that we don't know the distance even for
example the the distance to the gamma
reversed in the 90s in the early 90s
they didn't know whether they were in
the Galaxy or outside the Galaxy yeah
yeah right right right so but they still
could give these numbers very precisely
right
okay so hold on
so
I hate the fact that we're not defining
whether it's array or a point
I think that's going to cause us trouble
yes there is this this parameter inside
which perhaps this parameter is
especially important to be broken into
part so light time can have three values
and the observation value so it means
I'm looking at the light as it comes to
me
an emission which is
I'm emitting myself the light and I'm
saying the life the light will will
arrive at this event in at such a
distance
or geometric which means I'm using
instantaneous
propagation
and therefore I'm I'm referring to where
is okay can we zoom out for a second
okay
this these issues which we really need
to resolve is this the primary set of
things we need to resolve for Astro
stuff once we've nailed these have we
have we basically got the whole picture
or is there a whole bunch of other
design also to do I think this is main
thing for us to position
well but what about the other astral
functionality yes then astrographics has
the the The Styling
problems right but I think these are
things that
are more the choice of projection colors
things like that already knows which we
already discussed we have discussed
yesterday and and we could bring um
Jeremy and discuss a bit about this but
I think this is more or less clear okay
all right so let's go back to astral
position again
okay
so let me just understand I mean Stephen
it's not surprising that we get hung up
on Astra position this is the most
complicated object there is
yeah yeah I I know I know okay I'm not
I'm not complaining I'm just trying to
understand it no no okay
okay let's talk about a star Rachel or
something okay
when we give it to Astra position do we
in fact have the distance do we have its
point in space in space or not or do we
only have the ray
for some of them we do for others we do
not for this one I think we do
yeah yeah okay
but these I mean some we literally don't
know where they are
yep which is good enough for astral
graphics and it's good enough for Astro
angular separation it's not good enough
for astral distance Astro distance will
fail exactly if it's just the ray
exactly but we talked yesterday
apparently there's quite a lot of them
we don't know the distance yeah yeah
right right right so listen here's what
I think we should do I think we should
have a symbolic thing that we give for
the distance when we don't know the
distance
I see
so that it's very clear in the astral
position if we looked at astral position
it would be something like indeterminate
or something
now sometimes there may also be an
interval that we can give like we know
it's outside the Galaxy or something
like that
and that might be useful to give
but what I'm suggesting is
that
we always give
what we need
we always give enough coordinates to
quotes determine the position even if
one of those coordinates is
indeterminate so it didn't determine the
position it effectively just defined it
but array
okay so if we did that
then
and then by the way
you know Astro distance would just fail
or give indeterminate or whatever else
it does
right
yes
um for example as the position can
understand the directions too so when I
say astral position what is I don't know
the true Equinox
this is a Direction so it doesn't have a
notion of distance so let me just call
it interterminate I mean yeah
right now I'm saying it's on the
celestial sphere I know but I don't
think that's the right thing to do I
think that that the position needs to be
a position and if it turns out it's
array that is what do we do okay in in
geometry
okay we have how do we represent
you know we have a position x y z or we
have a line
we have the notion of a of a of a you
know of a ray right Roger a symbolic
representation array what does it look
like
um
well it has the similar parametrizations
like what is it called now and it's
called the
not half space half line
yeah but how what does half line have in
it it has it has don't look it up it has
basically a point of origin and a vector
right and actually I think it has two
parametrizations in it very cool yeah
that's two of them so if you look at the
second one there's a point of origin and
a vector
okay okay so the vector
yeah this is just a different
parametrization where we're saying that
because it's spherical coordinates
basically we're giving you know just the
radius is indeterminate I mean not for
the half line but we could have a heart
line we could have that representation
for a half line as well
where the half line has you know altered
has you know latitude longitude or Theta
Phi and then R is indeterminate
we don't happen to have you know V is a
vector
not is a three Vector it's a normalized
three Vector presumably not a Theta Phi
but it could be a Theta Phi
am I making sense
Roger American sense yeah it's something
we might consider adding to half line is
is the spherical version of half line
um
but personally this works in multiple
Dimensions so yeah this works okay but
so fine but I mean so so what we don't
have in the system
right and and you know okay okay this is
this is where spherical position is
relevant
because spherical position
could have the same issue that is just
like we have
a
you know we could Define a Theta Phi
with spherical position
without giving a radius for the sphere
or a spherical position could give Theta
Phi and a radius
am I making sense
yep so I mean Circle position normally
will just be on the unit sphere
presumably that will be its default but
we could also have an indeterminate
version which is an array and a version
which is on a sphere of a arbitrary
specified size so effectively what
sphere position spherical position
becomes is just a representation of a
point in spherical coordinates
right
which seems to me to make quite a bit of
sense so we should take that little
little monologue there and clip it out
and give it to Brad so
I mean normally we think of
I think of
um a point on the unit sphere in any
Dimension as generalization of
uh angle
yeah
okay let's go let's come back to the
sound design because I think this is a
decent understanding so the proposal is
that Astro position
is always
you know we can have short forms of how
to input it with pairs of numbers that
represent altitude Asom youth at your
current Point things like that but
astral position always simply represents
a
an absolute
space-time event
basically
well okay by event okay now this is the
other point just like its radial
distances indeterminate
so too
it's
it's time to be indeterminate as well
like the star rigel
well that's why it's important that we
consider these things observations
imagine that we don't know the distance
to write on
but we still get the the light at a
given point of very precise angles
so the way we handle this is by saying
okay this is not where risel is now this
is what radial was when it emitted the
light that we are receiving
stop
no but then we've got to put look the
question is what's in the source okay
your point is who cares what source
information was of when the light was
emitted all we care about is when it was
received exactly exactly problem is that
Astro position seems like it is pinning
things to the emitter
no no it to the Observer all this is
it's not no that's the subserver thing
that's different from astral position
look we've got two concepts here we've
got the emitter and we've got the
Observer
okay so the problem is
that
there are cases where we have a raw
emitter like Venus at a certain date
that's a raw emitter
something like rigel there are many
aspects of the emitter that we don't
know or care about
and the point that is at such and such
an altitude has in use is array
and if something is coming down that Ray
we don't really care where it came from
All We Care is how it's arriving right
okay
yep so
yeah that's why we were we were also
thinking here's another kind of use case
which is not sort of far away
observation but actually sort of
traveling around around solar systems
with satellites around Earth and
and nearby bodies in which case the
absolute
you know I mean to do orbital Dynamics
and all that stuff we kind of want the
absolute
all right let's go through this again
okay
all right so
if astral position represents
The observed position what do you
actually say in the documentation
does Astra position oh hold on let's
let's just let's just look at the
documentation yep
hmm
so astral position really represents an
observed astronomical position
maybe we can write that statement down
represents an observed astronomical
position
I don't know whether you want to
actually edit that I wouldn't edit that
I would just put it okay I'll put it
there and then okay um
okay astral position represents an
observed astronomical position
okay
now
then we say
uh
okay so one possibility is
it is an astronomical object
with a certain Observer specification so
one possibility is astral position of
obj
comma obs
if you write that down
will be J comma obs
okay that is of an object
by an observer
okay
another possibility
is that it is Astro position
of let's call them o chords
comma obs
no no o chords
not just chords o chords
because that's what it is it's the
observer's coordinate system the
coordinates that the Observer
is using to describe the object yep
now you know much like other things like
like
um you know I don't know I'm thinking of
inset or something there is a way in
which astral position might have
raw coordinates there in that first
argument
not the observer's coordinates the
service coordinates things like altitude
azimuth
but yes you could also specify
you know for the yes that bcrs thing is
a raw coordinates exactly exactly
exactly so these this is the case so the
VCRs is this raw coordinate system that
is defined everywhere in the solar
system and when we do this these
coordinates are instantaneous to this
date
so the VCRs automatically I get it I get
it I get it so I mean one one case is
it's Observer coordinate so that's one
case so so now you've also got abs
chords
and then
really the next case if you write it
down over there astral position
comma ABS chords
comma and then some kind of I don't know
what you call it coordinate systems you
know
then it's a coordinate system
which is a different thing from The
Observer because the coordinate system
no it doesn't it's it it's a reference
system again it's
it's an observer situated at the center
of the solar system but now the point is
that it's not following light
race it's it's kind of doing a
space like
yeah observation following that
foliation that is preferred
you know at the end of all of this we're
actually going to viscerally understand
relativity better than ever before
um
the
I don't like the term light time
yes it's it's standard terminology but
it is it yes
these are the so-called lifetime
correction
so the thing is that changing from one
to the other for objects that are very
close to us
and so people consider them Corrections
rather than different objects
so I consider separating the three of
them the the abstract observation the
position being instantaneous and then an
asteroid mission meaning that we are
emitting the light towards them rather
than vice versa
but then it gets more complicated
in the sense that you always have to
think about Which object you have
okay let's let's zoom out for a second I
mean the thing that you currently have
implemented
is there anything
definitively wrong with it other than
that we're slightly confused about
exactly what the semantics are
you throw in a frame you throw in the uh
position The Observer position you throw
in the Observer date
and
I don't think there is anything wrong
it's just the the design and this is
probably my style is kind of compact in
the sense that all the geoposition stuff
is is combined in a single powerful
super function
but this doesn't
prevent us from separating various parts
in the future if needed
if we prefer something else no no I
understand that but I look look the
issue is
I think it's important
this statement represents an observed
astronomical position I think that's a
useful statement to make it much less
confusing
yeah I'm saying I mean it doesn't
doesn't affect the the design it's just
explaining what the heck is going on
but
it depends on the value of this option
okay but but it's still conceptually
observed I mean observed where the speed
of light is assumed to be infinite
observed blah blah blah but it's
basically observed it's not
yes exactly I I see what you mean so
it's observed in this sense I was
explaining before that everything is
referred from these base point
that for us is the second argument yes
yeah
all right well
I still do think that um uh the astral
position altitude azimuth
should have that R should be well
presumably indeterminate in other words
that first usage there is equivalent to
the second usage with r being
indeterminate
um
I mean is it indeterminate or so large
that we don't know it
Infinity what do you want to call it I
mean
I'm not using Infinity because of the
packing issue
but perhaps it will be closer the
physical meaning is closer to Infinity
you've got this hacky number right yes
but I mean so we could just put Infinity
um
you know we could put infinity and you
can change it on you know on input
correct so something
inconvenient of using something like
indeterminate or Infinity is that it
doesn't work in condition coordinates in
the spherical coordinates you can
isolate the infinity into one number but
not in Cartesian
that's another advantage of using a fake
number
oh
well you can see the explicit scaling
look the phase number is going to get us
in trouble I guarantee the fake number
is going to get us some trouble
but you know it's a hack for now but I
think as much as possible we should
remove it
What what is the
okay the coordinate system there's a
Cartesian coordinates what is the
Cartesian which one is the Cartesian
coordinate system XYZ you give it the
three numbers x y z so this will be
Cartesian
but so if I want to convert
to Absolute x y z
in the bcrs frame yes you can do that
yeah what do I guess so for example I
can say
um I don't know again if this is
equatorial coordinates and now I want
them in Cartesian coordinates
right so now we have the XYZ values
that's freaking weird products relative
to what
relative to the Center of the Earth
equatorial coordinates yes
uh in icrs so bcrs this is now from the
center of the solar system
yeah okay
what was really weird that the Z
coordinate is the only one that's big I
don't understand that no no it's just
that it's it's switching these numbers
out of the same order of these numbers
it's just using you see it's Killer part
six oh it's killed posix
the the threshold is between these
numbers precisely what is TT
it means through equatorial true Equinox
so so the equator of the Earth
the equator of the earth is actually
kind of vibrating due to something
called mutation and so people have two
frames the average one and the true one
so this is a true one
and then there is the average which is
called mean
again this is standard notation but it's
weird meaning equator mean Equinox okay
all right look I think we're basically I
think basically the design you have is
as reasonable as we're going to get
I mean I think you know
right can you scroll down but
uh You misspelled light deflection by
the way title
left left hand side
oh yes I the DND HR was good
thank you
um
I heard there was a whole bunch of
scuttlebuckle up of the shapira actually
was the one behind the Shapiro time
delay but
who's to know
this is a super tiny effect I put it
there because it's very easy to add but
of all of them is is the smallest one
um
polar motion what does that mean
polar motion is an effect that considers
the fact that the axis of rotation on
the Earth does not coincide with the
geographic
or the rigid axis that's relevant for
coordinates like equatorial is that
right exactly if you want to convert
from the coordinate systems inside the
earth to those outside the Earth you
need to go through these values look I
think you should break those the that
table into things that relate to the
Earth and things that relate to you know
because bcrs couldn't care less about
polar motion right
uh exactly yes
yeah so some of these parameters do not
affect
some of the frames I think you should
say Earth observation parameters
relevant to authorization like
refraction is the same deal yep
oh so it does have a wavelength
parameter and refraction yes it is
therefore pressure temperature relative
humidity and wavelength given this as an
association
um yes I mean I think at the moment I'm
just passing a list of four but I I can
do that too I think you should allow an
association I think it should be
analogous to the things we do in
thermodynamic data in other words it
should be consistent with the with the
way we pass atmospheric information and
and I and I mean I don't know maybe we
even have the data and thermodynamic
data to be able to do a random methane
atmosphere or something I don't know I
don't I doubt it because we'd have to
have the profile of the atmosphere and
things
um
but yeah it should be consistent with
the way it's done in terminal Navigator
when we look up how it's done without
data
um
um yes I would okay but Epoch I think it
might be nice to qualify the word Epoch
slightly
yes so this is the difference between
data and Epoch is that some people want
to compare a measure an observation now
to an observation of 1950. and so there
are two problems one is that the thing
my might have moved and the other thing
is that the frame might have moved
so with these you can say I'm observing
today but I'm using the orientation of
the frame as it was in 1950. yep
I know Epoch is the standard term in
astronomy for that
but it's a word that is a bit abused in
astronomy but well kids can we qualify
it there
frame Epoch or something frame date
what what state versus observation date
it's the same these two these two are
open of sort are accepted
as meaning the same thing
and then say or
or I think yeah
okay
I wouldn't say instant of observation I
would say
date slash date
of observation I mean
that's what it is yep
okay so then then epoch
is the date defined that defines the
frame
yes
and the standard terminology here is of
date which means of today of this of the
observation date
or some people say of J 2000 for example
j2000 is a very important date
yeah in astronomy no I understand so so
but I think that's the
frame definition data or something or
frame definition epoch
will be a better name
I see
um
well
and you can say j2000 prison on the
quote straight 2000 yes yes
we can say here where was Rachel in meme
and that's this sort of bag of things
that you're giving there I mean you know
clearly many of those so you need to you
need to then
you know the epoch thing needs to be
something because because other things
this memmy thing does it also have a
form where you can say something Arrow
memmy
um listen listen listen listen what I
think should be the case with that
second argument is there is a full form
that is an association where everything
in it is named
I see and some of them you can just put
as just free-floating things in the way
that you're doing it I see we could have
a property that extracts that as an
association so you see yeah that's fine
that's a canonicalization but I think
that the the way you should document it
is there is an association you give all
the stuff but there is an alighted form
where some of those things can break out
of the association and just be
free-floating yep
again that way
yo you just Mark the ones like Epoch
that can be out of the association
right yes so at the moment it's frame
data and location those are the three
important ones I know but but but but
you're not giving okay so fine but but
you didn't give look oh okay okay so
you've got to indicate you gotta look
you gotta give a list of all of them
that can be in the association and then
you've got to say and these ones can be
free-floating yes that's missing indeed
okay all right okay now and the
coordinate system you're saying is a
separate argument to asteroid position I
think that's right
yes because it's very typical that you
just want to change that you just have
Cartesian and you want
um
we are about to run out of time but what
what other things do we have to cover I
mean we're getting really close here I
think we should you know should redo
this documentation and then we should
look at it one more time what do we need
to cover on this okay so so yesterday we
were discussing what what's the um
default so we wanted to have a default
that looked this this shape and then
there there are several asymmetal
projections and Jeff and I have been
looking at which ones are most used
and the main choices are typically
stereographic
which has the advantage to that is
conformal so angles are preserved but
and you see how these are all equivalent
spaces but they get longer so that's
that's uh that's like a Mercator as you
go farther away from the equator yes
so then a symmetal equidistance is is
very similar but now these are always
the same
okay well I mean this is the question I
suppose for Jeff and so I mean those
those little things where you have a
little circular slide ruly type thing
that shows you the configuration of the
Stars what projections are those using
it you mean like planospheres yes
I don't know off the top of my head
um you know I I I think uh stereographic
is the most common for example
astrolabes are based on on stereographic
projection
okay well that has a
um
so from the geometric point of view
stereographic is probably the most uh
well defined because it's circles and
lines are preserved as circles I mean
astral labels have been used for what
two thousand years or something
um
yeah so I tend to think the
stereographic is probably the best one
by default okay yeah
okay and we've got some coloring choices
and things like that to make
and then if we specify
okay now in astral graphics
we had that some of those additional
parameters
so I mean you should be able to bank
specify okay you've got the Astro
Observer option which I don't like at
all in astral Graphics which is
basically saying given the astral
positions
this is what you want to change
what are you trying to do with astross
in a sense imagine that you have a bunch
of absolute positions in the first
argument
The Observer is going to compute the
observations for all of them and then
put them all together here
so in essence Geographics is doing the
same it's selecting a point at the
center it's doing all the computations
implicitly for displacements and then
presenting them in a map
I understand but astral position might
have already done that and now you want
to
now you want to convert to a different
map
like you want to change your position on
the earth for example
yes
and so it's kind of like a show in
graphics with a different Viewpoint or
something
but then you have to you have to redo
the computation so it's not possible to
say I have an observation what will be
my observation from a different place
based on this one I know I know I know
you've got all kinds of relativistic
things and lots of stuff going on right
because priority the object has moved
and we don't know where he went it went
yeah right I understand so
basically
the second argument of Astral position
the association that was given the
second argument of Astral position
everything that occurred in there you
want to be able to put into Astro
graphics
with
uh and it will
convert
whatever the inferred actual astral
positions of the objects were in the
first argument
not the observed astral positions but
the absolute astral positions and then
use the new
observation specification
to decide how to present those in the
Astro Graphics is that right
yes effectively if we have Astra
positions here already what this is
going to do is that it will take the
orientation of the frame in The Observer
and reorient these ones it's not going
to recompute the observation because it
cannot be done
once we I mean if we have to observe a
star or
and Imagine That You observe Pluto from
the Earth
yeah now you say what would be the same
observation from Mars well this cannot
be done because from Mars the timing
will be different and we don't know
yeah from a master position
exactly what you want well
wait a minute so we can't change the
Astro
observe observation that much we can
only accept some things in it to
continue the the orientation the the
coordinate system Etc but the base point
is is essentially only informative to
reconstruct the event
why do we need the base point it's
astral graphics
well because if you have objects here
like Mars Etc you have to use the base
point to know the observation
but what I mean is that once you have
performed an astro observation wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait the point is if the thing that
is given us the first argument is a pure
object like Mars that has not been
resolved into coordinates
you're saying you have to know more
things in order to know how to resolve
it into coordinates exactly yep
so that's a somewhat I mean it might be
in it
whereas if it's already been resolved
then what are you going to do with the
with the specification of coordinates
that are given in the second argument
sometimes you won't be able to do
anything because it will have already
been resolved and you can't change that
resolution as you say but there might be
in different coordinate systems so I
have to kind of conform them to the one
that is specified by The Observer I know
but what if you've been given an
absolute position in astral position the
first argument astral Graphics you're
given one absolute Astro position and
one object specification like Mars
what do you do
well I will use the Observer to observe
Mars and then I will reorient the
abstract position given
than that exactly so imagine that you're
going to present one of these uh
although a connection of positions of
Mars
right I understand it the astral
position oh I see what you're saying you
say you don't even want to do that but
if the astral position actually did have
a space-time event encoded in it you
could make a correction
well if you had a trajectory if you have
a word line you can observe the word
line from different events and you
always intersect the word line with a
light Ray
but if you give just a point of self
from another one and you go to another
observation Point most probably you will
not intersect the original event
yeah
by the way I mean you know given what
we're doing here we probably should I
mean presumably we could stick a black
hole and I mean given that we actually
have gravitational lensing
built into this
we could presumably I mean does the
gravitational lensing computation that
we have here work if you stick a black
hole in it
well the the system is prepared to
follow exactly what we know the physics
of the solar system is
we could change the physic and say and
this is the solar system plus a black
hole that has appeared instantaneously
here
but we are not providing
a way to do that yet okay fine but but I
mean we still need to get the outside
the solar system coordinate so that we
can do lensing around galaxies and stuff
like this right exactly
I think it's going to be quite useful to
do that I think people are going to
really like it
somehow that would need some sort of
environment physics variable would you
specify my physics is the solar system
or my physics is a black hole somewhere
and then so you guys are all focused on
these very far away events I think it's
way more exciting the fact that we can
travel around our solar system and
become multi-planetary
that's you know I understand I
understand both things are relevant I
mean there's both you know notice that a
very big expensive telescope just got
launched that's about to produce tons
and tons of data on things well aware
absolutely
so people are going to care about that
just as they're going to care about you
know space operations so to speak where
you know you have whatever transfer
orbits going to wherever it is exactly
yes
RBS on our live streams asking can we do
an asteroid simulation yes we can do an
asteroid we know where lots of minor
planets are we know their families
we know lots of stuff for this
yes it will change to the series yeah
it is
there are moons it's also fun to do a
Calista
you know I really do think that the that
the icon there should be a position of
the altitude that was used if we know it
right given that given that this is
Altitude Azimuth why not just put up why
not just use that that telescope when we
don't know her you know when we only
know it array it's horrifying I mean I
think we should put up the planosphere
type thing you know put up the
stereographic projection with a dot in
it
oh I see like a little version of this
one yeah but just a DOT that's a very
small graphic I mean maybe it'll
translate I don't know no you don't
understand I'm just saying that you can
put the plane in the ecliptic in there
if you want but nothing else you're just
putting one dot that represents the
altitude atom use
I see all right
it's doable
yeah I mean you might as well you can
give the play with ecliptic and you give
the one dot what I think I see
that will have the advantage that it's
generalizable to when we have several
points because we have this yes yes
that's nice right just like the gear
position case yep
um
all right we've got a wrap for now
um why don't you you know there's some
redocument you know there's some
documentation tune up and a little bit
of other stuff yeah and then let's take
a look at this one more time let's bring
Jeremy in let's um uh look at um
um
okay
uh but this is really lovely I mean it's
really lovely it's great it's and it's
fascinating
to see I mean I guess this is what
people spent the 1700s and 1800s
worrying about
getting all the stuff right and they did
it all on paper
well yes they did I have a bunch of
those books from people like um Adams
and
leverier and all these all these and
discovering Neptune yeah yeah but they
have all all these hand calculations of
all these power series expansions and so
on
um
it's all quite impressive uh
and um I mean it's
um I mean I do think in terms of how to
kill a rap that drove resources into it
which was navigation
except that Neptune wasn't that relevant
to that I mean but so they can spend a
bit free time on on you know the hobby
the ruins of Jupiter almost made you
know a killer navigation time keeping
mechanism but they didn't quite make it
oh I've never heard that story oh
absolutely yeah people were going to use
that for but they perturb each other so
over the long term it doesn't behave I
know but locally I mean they had tables
right so locally that was a way of
figuring out I'm now forgetting but that
was that was a scheme for longitude
wasn't it
using the transit times of the moons of
Jupiter
it must have I mean the way you describe
it it sounds like it yeah
um
anyway
uh well very nice very very nice
um I I do think given that we've gotten
this far in getting all the physics we
should go further and you know we should
do the the you know deep deep space
of um you know I mean within the Galaxy
outside the solar system or within the
Galaxy can we do stuff there we have
Galactic coordinates but we don't have
we don't have enough to be able to do
everything properly is that true
um right
yeah so
perhaps we'll have to start by by going
a bit outside the solar system and
getting because we know the distance to
to many of the Stars around us
so perhaps we're going to start yeah I
mean obviously the the the thing that we
should be able to do which I know you
know we've been able to do for years in
some form is just to make the 3D picture
of the local Stars which should be easy
for us right now because we just take
Cartesian
you know we're just using astral
position with Cartesian and then we're
getting out three coordinates right and
one one thing we need to look at next
time
is the access or functions to get things
like raw coordinates out of Astral
position
right yeah so it would be
it would be basically this time we have
the the XYZ coordinates right
yeah so then the first argument would be
these numbers in
right
all right I gotta go excellent work
let's see it one more time hopefully in
the next week or so
um
and uh take it from there
okay thank you see you all soon